Whose land is this?
My land.
♪
William: Well, well, well.
Our war hero has arrived.
William: You made a good choice coming back here.
The Osage are the finest,
William: wealthiest,
William: and most beautiful people on God’s earth.
William: They outsmarted everybody.
♪
William: They have the say
William: who gets the oil.
♪
William: Son, I got a question.
You like women?
That’s my weakness.
[LAUGHS]
♪
William: Well we mix these families together
William: and that estate money
flows the right direction. It’ll come to us.
♪
Mollie: Sho-mee-kah-see.
Mollie: That’s how you are.
♪
I don’t know what you said
but it must’ve been Indian for handsome devil.
[LAUGHS]
♪
Why did you come here?
Ernest: I work with my uncle.
You scared of him?
♪
No, he’s a…
Ernest: the nicest man in the world.
♪
William: The Osage,
William: their time is over.
♪
William: We’ve got to take back control of our home.
Tom: I was sent down from Washington, D.C.
to see about these murders.
♪
Paul: We have so many deaths we’ve lost count.
William: It’s just
bad luck.
Tom: Seems more like an epidemic than bad luck to me.
♪
Paul: The Osage is dying by the enemy.
Do not let them die alone.
Mollie: Evil surrounds my heart.
♪
William: You gotta pick a side.
Mollie: I don’t even know if you love me anymore.
Of course I love you.
♪
Mollie: Then kill these men who killed my family
Tom: Did your wife say who she was most afraid of?
♪
[SCREAMING]
William: Don’t do something you’re gonna regret
for the rest of your life.
♪
Ernest: I ain’t got nothing but regret.